all right how you doing people i'm dave
rubin it's the reuben report direct
message on february 17th 2022. i realize
we're starting about a minute and a half
late and i want everybody to calm down
we had some sort of technical issue
and we brought the team we all sat down
we go my god there's something happening
and then we just uh we unplugged it and
plugged it back in and uh here we are so
i think we're gonna be okay we are live
streaming on rumble youtube and blaze tv
if you have not subscribed yet on rumble
do me a favor and do that because uh i
don't know if you've heard about this
but big tech is evil
and the pipes that we are all
communicating on will not remain for
very long it's very very obvious this is
connected to what's going on in canada
all of the free speech stuff that we've
all talked about for years and there
just aren't safe places for free speech
online uh yet we're working on it over
at locals in rumble uh some so do me a
favor and subscribe to our rumble
channel rumble.com reuben report and we
have a big show for you today uh we're
gonna dive into some cobid stuff that is
actually on the positive side of covid
of course then we will have to show you
something from anthony fauci who's
completely insane and then crazy
children demanding that they stay in
masks forever then the second story i
want to cover today is this huge story
that sort of got got pushed aside
probably in a normal week would have
been the number one story but in essence
that the clinton campaign has basically
been caught
spying on the trump campaign
from before trump became president and
that they sort of set up the whole uh
trump is colluding with russia thing
and
it's almost like they do the bad thing
and then they say the other guy's doing
the bad thing uh so this is not really
getting much mainstream coverage i
actually wanted to wait you know the
story was breaking over the last couple
days from this durham report and you
know with in light of everything that
was going on with canada i was really
kind of focused on that but i also kind
of wanted to wait and see
you know give people a chance to analyze
the report properly see if it sort of
had weight if there was heft and some
truth there it sounds like there is so
i'm going to give it to you as straight
as i can and uh what you do with that is
up to you and then finally yeah we're
gonna go back to canada because justin
trudeau i mean the guy
is just doubling down he has a chance i
don't even know if he has it anymore he
had a chance to just
tie this thing up nicely and and go home
he did not have to do this emergency
powers thing he did not have to threaten
free citizens of canada
with freezing their bank account and
everything else that he's doing they are
now stopping peaceful protesters in
ottawa police are out in ottawa on the
streets handing out notices warning
people to get off the streets this is
not what is supposed to happen in a
western democracy okay
this is the type of thing that if it was
happening in say egypt
we'd be talking about invading them or
we'd be making sure that the president
wouldn't be the president much longer
sadly uh not getting much out of our
administration about what's happening
over there in canada but we'll get to
that too uh before we do any of that i
want to talk to you guys about chamonix
you know red inflamed and blotchy uneven
skin tone can be a struggle for all of
us and what about fine lines forehead
wrinkles and under eye puffiness the
only solution has been abrasive
irritating products with retinol until
now thanks to jenyasel's new ultra
retinol cream see all the skin healing
benefits of retinol and the hydrating
effects of
hyaluronic hydrologic higher lonic how
would you say that someone help me here
he gave me the hyrulonic i think that's
it acid without harsh irritation
hyrulonic all right that sounds like
something uh janusel's retinol
alternative cream uses clinical
concentrations of a natural alternative
to correct red inflamed skin visibly
reduce wrinkles and even out skin tone
made for sensitive skin it's effective
hydration for all skin types perfect for
both men and women get janusel's
ultraretinol included with your order of
their most popular package today at
genusl.com
dave save over 60 percent on genusl
favorites plus enter my special code
dave for an extra discount at checkout
visit the new januselle.com to bundle
your skincare favorites and get 10
off for as long as you love the results
you'll see
genuscell.com that's
g-e-n-u-c-e-l-e dot com dave g-e-n you
g-e-n-u-c-e-l
dot com slash dave all orders upgraded
to free priority shipping for a limited
time genusell.com dave and now back to
me we may have to unplug me and plug me
back in
let's see what happens all right let's
talk a little bit about covet and you
know my policy on this i'm really trying
to focus on the good things related to
covid when mask mandates go away when uh
vaccine mandates go away when people
push back when we do things related to
individual choice and such
well with that in mind we've got a good
story for you so you all know that glenn
younkin is the new governor of virginia
he ran on a sort of anti-mandate
promise as well as the thing that really
got him in was sort of getting crt and
woke-ism out of the schools because they
had all sorts of problems in virginia
and the ridiculous democrat he ran
against this terry mcauliffe was was
saying really crazy things like parents
have no right to say what their kids are
going to be taught i mean just the usual
nonsense well younkin there was a little
bit of a fear like oh he's going to get
in there and then he just won't do
anything well he's actually doing some
stuff he just signed a bill making mask
mandates illegal
in virginia but don't take my word for
it take his
it is my distinct privilege and honor
to be able to sign senate bill
739
into law in the commonwealth of virginia
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
isn't that refreshing like joy people
together standing outside applauding
that they can make decisions for
themselves this isn't going to stop
anyone from wearing a mask if you would
like to wear a mask if you would like to
send your child to school in a mask if
you're a teacher and you want to wear a
mask whatever it may be you can wear a
mask but mandates the idea that the
government that one power to rule over
all of us
that they will have the power to force
you to do something that is now illegal
in virginia this is a massive
win
for freedom in the united states i
thought it was an important story to
talk about because when we get wins we
got to acknowledge it we got to
acknowledge it and then we have to
replicate that throughout the country so
this is a really really beautiful moment
and then of course i thought well it's
not always beautiful there's some
problems and we found this video
yesterday because things things are not
perfect unfortunately the the damage
that the mainstream media and fouchy and
the cdc and the nih the damage that they
have done to young people
not just in terms of what it's like to
wear a mask all the time but the
psychological damage
of making everyone afraid of everything
that that none of this can go away till
we have zero copied it is real and when
i saw this video i was like this can't
be real and yet it is this is a group of
students at the university of nevada
protesting that the mask mandate is
being lifted there they want more masked
mandates yes really video
[Music]
i like when she's saying reinstate it
sort of like ree
you know the internet meme read
reinstate mask mandates i mean
really like
joking aside this is like
this is pretty upsetting actually that
they have done damage to these those are
17 18 19 year old kids damaged to the
point
that they want
to reinstate mandates so that they can
keep the cloth that's on their faces the
very same cloth that now the cdc
says uh you know will not do anything
they want everyone to be in this stuff
forever these kids are under virtually
no threat
from kovid they can wear the masks if
they want to wear the masks they don't
have to wear the mask if they don't want
to but that they would be out there
marching for mandates is absolutely
crazy i do want to clarify one thing
that the uh order
that uh youngkin signed is that it is
illegal
for schools not absolutely everything so
okay it's not perfect right but step by
step and i think actually getting the
mass mandates out of schools where kids
are young we know that the recovery
rates are crazily high that virtually no
one's under threat the teachers are all
vast blah blah blah it's a great move so
it's like we show you one thing that's
great
one thing not so great i mean the damage
to young people that they have done they
have done something that we just can't
imagine the repercussions of this like
what when those kids
and their kids right 18 year old when
they're when they're say 25 35 45 and
they're in the world like what sort of
crazy things are they going to be voting
for what sort of crazy policies because
of what the world did to them are they
going to be pushing for you i don't i
actually don't know the answer it would
be it would be hard to imagine and one
of the people who led us to this crazy
moment where young people would demand
that they have to wear things on their
faces and that other people have to wear
things on their faces and that we do it
indefinitely one of the guys who got us
into that mess was anthony fauci and
here's anthony fauci and you're not
going to believe it guys he's thinking
about more shots
the potential future requirement for an
additional boost or a fourth shot for
mrna or a third shot for j j
is being very carefully monitored in
real time
and recommendations if needed will be
updated according to the data as it
evolves
first off i don't even know what he
means by requirement anymore required
for what required by who
like i know you want endless power dude
but i just can't imagine and i get it
like i i've chosen
the the idea set that i believe in the
idea set that you believe in is somewhat
similar to mine i can't imagine that
anyone i just can't imagine the mental
state that someone would be in where
they'd be watching fauci
two years after all of this nonsense
started being like oh he now wants me to
get a fourth shot that sounds right
the shot sure must work because now i
got to get a fourth one or a third one a
j and j et cetera et cetera but i want
to throw to the video again can we throw
the video can we do a little b-roll here
what has happened where are his eyes the
man has lost his eyes and what i think
happened i tweeted this out yesterday it
seems to me that his soul
whatever was left of his soul has
actually burst forth through his eye
sockets and now what's happening is his
eyelids are just covering the endless
abyss that is him there's nothing left
in him anymore you understand he does
like this all the time okay
i just i can't imagine why people would
listen to him listen don't listen to me
i'm not a doctor
listen to yourself listen to your own
doctor listen to you know the people
around you but i just
okay now four shots five shots six shots
eighteen boosters monthly boosters buy
seven boosters get nine free like it's
never going to stop with these crazy
people
let's talk about start mail for just a
moment you ever wonder how big tech
knows so much about you well i got three
words for you free email services when
you click accept on those terms and
conditions you're giving that free email
provider the go ahead to scan and
analyze your email free email services
are data hoarders if you're done letting
big tech make billions by selling your
info i suggest switching to start mail
start mail keeps your email private
period every email can be encrypted even
if the recipient doesn't use encryption
when you delete an email in start mail
it's gone forever and start mail uses
their own servers not amazons which
means they can't be put out of business
if you're already dropping big data
hoarders like facebook and jumping onto
less censored platforms then right now
is the perfect time to switch to start
mail switching to start mail is seamless
too you can easily transfer all your
current email data so there's no
starting from scratch start mail is
backed by the most stringent privacy
laws in the world you get unlimited
anonymous aliases so when you're giving
an email to a company but want to
protect your identity start mail can
generate a shareable alias email so
people can't sell your info and they can
be deleted at any time i keep saying the
way to the way forward is to build
competitive businesses that support our
privacy values which is why i value the
service start mail provides your cyber
security has never been more at risk
email snoops and scammers are taking
advantage of the pandemic as phishing
has skyrocketed in the last year keep
your private info private with start
mail sign up today and you'll get 50 off
your first year go to
startmail.comruben that's start mail
s-t-a-r-t
mail.com ruben for 50 off your first
year startmail.com
reuben and now back to me i think it's
hyrulonic acid i think i did it right
there did that sound right to you guys
hyrulonic okay i got yeah everybody okay
they love the hyaluronic acid around
here all right so i do want to uh talk
about the the other big story that sort
of didn't become a big story because it
kind of goes against the narrative and
we had this whole canada thing and as i
said at the top of the show i kind of
wanted to wait a couple days to see
where this thing shook out see how legit
it might be but really the big story of
the last couple days is that uh special
counsel john durham who has been
investigating
whether trump had something to do with
russia or where some spying came from
and did hillary have anything to do with
it he dropped his report a couple days
ago so i'm going to read a bunch here
from the daily wire we tried to condense
it in a way to just give you enough to
get the bare bones facts out of this and
then we'll talk about it in just a sec
from the daily wire special counsel john
durham who is investigating the origins
of the fbi's trump russia probe says in
a new court filing that lawyers for the
clinton campaign paid a tech company to
infiltrate servers belonging to trump
tower and the trump white house in an
effort to establish a narrative linking
president donald trump to russia the
revelation was made in a court filing
late last week that centered on
potential conflicts of interest
connected to the representation of
former clinton campaign lawyer michael
sussman who has been charged with
allegedly lying to the fbi
the indictment against sussman says he
told then fbi general counsel james
baker in september of 2016
less than two months before the 2016
presidential election that he was not
doing work for any client when he
requested and held a meeting in which he
presented purported data and white
papers that allegedly demonstrated a
covert
communications channel between the trump
organization and alpha bank which has
ties to the kremlin
but durham's filing on february 11th in
a section titled factual background
reveals that sussman had assembled and
conveyed the allegations to the fbi on
behalf of at least two specific clients
including a tech executive
and a us-based internet company and the
clinton campaign the filing says that
during the summer of 2016 the tech
executive worked with sussman an
investigative firm retained by a law
firm on behalf of the clinton campaign
and employees at tech companies to
gather
data okay so let's just pause for one
second i know that that's a lot and
that's why these stories even when they
come out it seems like something's there
people are just like ah it's too much to
deal with tech companies somebody called
somebody and there was a lawyer and okay
what happened
the basic bones of it are that durham
now is alleging that they have evidence
that the clinton campaign in essence was
spying on computers that were at trump
tower
two months before the election and then
it sounds like it leaks into once trump
actually was president so let's continue
from the daily wire president joe
biden's campaign also hired the tech
firm that former secretary of state
hillary clinton alleged allegedly hired
to spy on former president donald trump
and link him to russia the biden
campaign paid nearly twenty thousand
dollars to a cyber security firm at the
center of special counsel john durham's
investigation into the origins of the
trump russia probe the campaign paid new
star information services in 2020 for
accounting and compliance work according
to federal election commission records
according to durham nustar's chief
technology officer rodney joff accessed
sensitive web traffic data that the
company maintained on behalf of the
white house executive office in order to
collect derogatory information about
donald trump
jaffe allegedly provided the information
to hillary clinton campaign lawyer
michael sussman who in turn gave it to
the cia during a meeting in february
2017. durham charged sussman in
september with lying to the fbi about
his investigation of trump as ross noted
in the report the fact that biden paid
the same firm during the 2020
presidential election
also raises questions
uh of whether or not the firm was paid
for the same type of activity namely
whether jaffe continued snooping on
trump in the most recent
election
okay i get it it's a lot but i think you
can sort of see it sounds like
it sounds like and the durham report
will be analyzed people are going to
continue looking at it it's going to be
ignored by mainstream media this is the
type of thing where if we had a
mainstream media that we could trust and
the durham report was dropped well the
mainstream media might cover it honestly
and say boy you know we actually have
covered it because we're fair and
impartial and we've debunked these you
know 10 points here or we found you know
three inconsistencies here etc etc
instead they're going to ignore it
because it kind of makes hillary look a
bit guilty so i think you sort of see
that in what we laid out right there uh
but the white house at the moment uh is
not are we gonna go to the hillary clip
first we'll go to we'll go to hillary
clinton first all right so first we've
got hillary who she was in new york city
and she got questioned about what was
going on
hilary laura collins daily mail did you
pay to spy on the trump campaign what
are you going to comment on the spying
allegations hillary
did you pay for the having spied on
all right so hillary's not going to
comment on that i don't blame you
hillary that's just fine okay but at
least you know there is someone who is a
journalist somewhere trying to get some
information from somebody that's pretty
good you know for 2022 that's like
bullet surprise stuff uh now we've got
two clips this is karine jean-pierre
and jenn saki you know jen saki she's
the white house press secretary karine
jean-pierre is sort of her sidekick or
when when saki is out for the afternoon
or has a headache or just can't go to
work whatever it is she jumps in there
now they are actually being questioned
about this and uh surprise surprise they
don't want to talk about it
hillary laura
um of competing candidates or even the
president-elect to you for the goal of
creating a narrative is that something
that
that's something i can't speak to from
this podium so i refer you to the
department of justice
in that report monitoring
internet traffic
is is that spying again i can't speak to
that report you i i refer you to
department of justice generally speaking
that with monitoring internet traffic
trying to give my answers that i could
change i refer you to department of
justice i can't speak to that from here
there was an outside company with ties
to the clinton camp
monitoring server data info on the
executive office of the president
through the obama administration
possibly into the trump administration
do you know if there's still a system
picking up
server data on the eop and if not when
it stopped again i i know you asked my
colleague a few questions about this the
other day but i would point you any
questions about this at the department
of justice and then is what was
described in the filing there
monitoring internet traffic is that
generally speaking would that be
considered something
long lines of spying again i would point
you to the department of justice go
ahead okay so obviously they're not
going to comment on this it's
interesting that they're referring
people to the department of justice
because i guess if the department of
justice starts getting asked questions
about this they might have to look into
it and they might find something that
they might not like so in essence just
to like really like in the most simplest
terms so if you're sitting at dinner
tonight and someone's asking you about
this or did you hear about that
nonsensical report in essence the durham
report is saying that hillary clinton's
campaign
paid a firm to spy on the servers at
trump tower when it was the office of
the president-elect and then potentially
into the administration and what now
links this to the current administration
is that the biden campaign used the same
firm in 2020. so i'm not going to sit
here and tell you that i know exactly
what this fully means and that hillary
was absolutely aware and everything else
but now do you see how when we had four
years of the media running around saying
that trump was compromised by the
russians and he was a russian spy or a
russian asset and that there were emails
back and forth then blah blah blah do
you think that maybe it had a little
something to do with this and does it
seem a little bit weird that the hillary
clinton campaign whether she knew it or
not
was paying a firm to spy on the
president-elect are we allowed to do
that here in the united states well
interestingly remember the orange man
the guy who's been banned from
everything the guy with the funny hair
well he was on 60 minutes a couple years
ago when he was president
talking about
the fact that he was spied on and leslie
stahl was not happy about it so the
biggest scandal was when they spied on
my campaign they spied on my campaign
there's no real evidence of that of
course there is it's all over the place
leslie they spied on my campaign and
they got caught can i say something
you know this is 60 minutes
and we can't put on things we can't
verify put it on because it's bad for
biting we can't put on things we can't
verify leslie they spied on my campaign
well we can't very it's funny i'm
totally verified no
it's been just go down and get the
papers
they spied on my campaign they got
caught no and then they went much
further than that and they got caught
and you will see that leslie and you
know that but you just don't want to put
it on there as a matter of fact i don't
know that
okay so the durham report is saying that
trump was right now again
if we had a trusted media we would have
legal experts we'd have forensic experts
looking into this and then hopefully
presenting the report to us in a way
that enough of us would be able to go
okay it's either true or false or
everything else i haven't seen anyone
i've really tried i really tried
yesterday and this morning to look into
people that were debunking the report i
have not seen anything that was sort of
a clear debunking of the report mostly
it's just like ah
it's just [ __ ] you know it's just
trump conspiracy theory blah blah blah
the usual the usual nonsense well now
that this has come out
trump
he's diving back in here's what he had
to say he said the latest pleading from
special counsel john durham provides
indisputable evidence that my campaign
and presidency were spied on by
operatives paid by the hillary clinton
campaign in an effort to develop to
develop a completely fabricated
connection to russia this is a scandal
far greater in scope and magnitude than
watergate and those who were involved in
and knew about this spying operation
should be subject to criminal
prosecution in a stronger period of time
in our country this crime would have
been punishable by death
in addition reparations should be paid
to those in our country who have been
damaged by this okay so let me just uh
for just a second trump is trump okay so
i'm
should people be punished by death
should we be talking about reparations
okay let's just put that aside for just
a second um but what he what he is
basically saying is hey you know uh
we're supposed to have free and fair
elections here and i was elected and
when i was on the way to be elected
because we got those few months before
you know between the election and
between well election and when i was
sworn in they were spying on me that is
exactly what durham is laying out he is
saying that the campaign the hillary
campaign paid this firm to do that and
then flash forward four years that the
biden campaign work with this same firm
we do need to know about this right like
we honestly do need to know about this
whether you fully believe it whether
that was sort of the the genesis of how
the media then decided to run around for
four years calling you know trump a
russian spy and all that stuff or not
it's like we do need to know what
happened here because otherwise how can
we ever have
a transfer of power that's going to make
sense right like our campaigns allowed
to just spy on each other set up you
know software on servers and all of
those things
now again i keep bringing this back to
the fact that we don't have an honest
media to analyze this so that we'll be
able to get to some kind of consensus on
this i'm just doing the best i can to
read the information and convey it to
you in an understandable way well then
there's this clown uh jimmy kimmel you
guys all know this jimmy kimmel guy and
the only reason i even bring up this
clip is because he's talking about the
durham story and unfortunately because
our media is so dead brain dead and just
awful plenty of people seemingly get
their news from these late night hosts
not that their ratings are so great but
people do watch them for news because
they have all become activists like they
do politics all night long so here's
what jimmy kimmel has
has to say about the durham story
meanwhile trump's terrible kids are
making the rounds
desperately trying to protect the golden
goose last night eric took time out of
his busy schedule to promote this
made-up hillary clinton spying case
they're now pumping into the fox news
viewers soft oatmeal like brain
the fox news viewers soft oatmeal like
brains i mean he's saying that to his
audience who i'm fairly certain at all
i'm going to say the r word they've told
me not to say the r word uh they're
they're not bright people that are
watching jimmy kimmel uh jimmy kimmel is
also a big blackface enthusiast there's
jimmy kimmel in blackface there he is
pretending he's carl malone yeah and he
talks in third person and makes fun of
the way that carl malone talks and it's
not just jimmy kimmel in blackface
there's his do we have his girlfriend
yeah there's his ex-girlfriend there's
sarah silverman in blackface that's
weird being a blackface guy and dating a
blackface girl and you know mocking
other people for having soft like brains
you obvious racist person you must be by
your own rules you're an evil racist and
and should be banned and censored and
all of those things right that's how we
play this game but not making about
jimmy kimmel's blackface um you know he
goes after trump's kids there i just
want to say you know i become pretty
good friends with don jr specifically he
is a good guy he is a good family man he
loves his kids um he he is a decent guy
fighting for what he believes and i i
just have no doubt that he's a better
person than jimmy kimmel i just have no
doubt like it's not even close um i i
know eric a tiny bit i met ivanka once
like they they are basically good people
okay i can't sit here and tell you i
know every little thing about them but
just the way he dismisses them you know
it's funny like
they're not crack addicts joe biden has
a crack addict son if you want to talk
about presidents and former presidents
and their children i don't necessarily
blame joe biden for his crack addict son
but you know we're not allowed to talk
about that right like when that story
was breaking during the election that's
when new york post got banned from
twitter and we if you posted the story
anywhere you were gonna get banned from
facebook and everywhere else so uh i
don't like jimmy kimmel very much not a
good guy not a fan of the jimmy kimmel
and speaking of people i'm not a fan of
uh let's finish up with what's going on
in canada because obviously this story
is not going anywhere and i think one of
the things that justin trudeau is really
going to prey on right now is that the
media will just move on the worldwide
media which has basically ignored what's
happening up there or when they do cover
it we've shown you some of the stuff
from cnn and msnbc they basically mock
the people who are protesting
peacefully and fighting for their rights
in an honest way the way you're supposed
to do it in a free society i think
trudeau now that he's ramped up all of
these emergency powers he's hoping that
you know some other stories will happen
maybe maybe we could get a war in
ukraine or something and people will
stop paying attention um but
it is ramping up in canada that is the
simple truth they are literally i saw a
video this morning they are have police
going out in ottawa handing out flyers
to people saying that you will be
arrested or fined if you're out on the
streets right now we covered already uh
this insanity related to how they will
look into the people who donated to some
of the crowd funding that was supporting
the truckers i mean it's really nuts
stuff and now here is one of justin
trudeau's ministers
talking about how they will target trump
supporters what look you've just
compared people who may have donated to
this to the same people who are funding
maybe a terrorist i just want to be
clear here sir this is really important
a lot of folks says look i just don't
like your vaccine mandates and i donated
to this now it's illegal should i be
worried that the bank can freeze my
account what's your answer to that
well if i think if you if you are a
member uh of you know a pro-trump
movement who's donating hundreds of
thousands of dollars and millions of
dollars to this kind of thing
then you ought to be
worried did you catch that did you catch
that these are bad people
we live in a time where the people who
pretend to be the good people are the
bad people
um you're allowed to do with your money
what you see fit most of the people
first off what's he talking about the
people if you're a member of a trump
movement who donated hundreds of
thousands or millions of dollars what is
he talking about this was all completely
grassroots now there may be somebody who
is a big trump supporter who donated a
bunch of money but that we know that
there were thousands and thousands of
people who were thrown in 25 bucks 50
bucks just to support these people not
to support violence not to support
racism just to support people's right to
fight for what they believe in and do it
peacefully and that's exactly what they
were doing and now and now trudeau and
this clown these are the people that are
escalating this nonsense uh but the way
they link it you see what they're doing
they're linking it to something having
to do with trump and they're going to
somehow try to link it so that the
people who are the truckers that they're
the racists and that's sort of like the
racists that support trump and january
sixth inter insurrection and trucker
insurrection like you can see how the
machine morphs ah it's evil but i admire
it's evil i don't admire it's evil i
admire the way it does it like the
disgusting way it does it right in front
of our faces and we always have to react
to it like you got to give the devil his
due on that right this thing is evil it
does it right in front of us
but finally what might be happening up
in canada is that their conservative
party which basically has been a liberal
party they've got a liberal party and a
conservative party they're very very
similar they also have the people's
party of canada which is sort of their
libertarian party led by maxine bernier
who i just taped an interview with we're
going to put up tomorrow that's sort of
the more real libertarian like
government get out of my way party but
in essence they've had this liberal
party that trudeau is the head of and
they have the conservative party they
don't have much difference the
conservative party pretty much just bows
to the liberal party
um but finally it does seem that the
conservative party might be
getting some balls they might just be
ready to stand up to this guy we've
mentioned how a couple of the premieres
in some of the provinces they are not
going to listen to trudeau they're
they're pushing against uh these
emergency powers well yesterday a jewish
conservative and you'll see why i
mentioned that she's jewish a jewish
conservative member of parliament
started going after trudeau and just
listen just listen to the way he
dismissed her hopeful vision for public
life isn't a naive dream it could be a
powerful force for change if canadians
are to trust their government their
government needs to trust canadians
those are the words of the prime
minister in 2015.
these people very often misogynistic
racists women haters science deniers the
fringe same prime minister six years
later as he fans the flames of an
unjustified national emergency so mr
speaker when did the prime minister lose
his way when did it happen
[Applause]
prime
[Applause]
mr
minister
conservative party members can stand
with people who wave swastikas they can
stand with people who waive the
confederate flag we will choose to stand
with canadians who deserve to be able to
get to their jobs to be able to get
their lives back these illegal protests
need to stop and they will mr speaker
[Applause]
justin trudeau is an evil soulless
lizard person there is nothing real
about that cardboard cutout of a human
being
she's using his words against him now
she happens to be jewish from what i
understand she lost family members in
the holocaust okay and then he dares say
that oh you stand with people who wave
swastikas and and stand for the
confederate flag which by the way where
are all the videos on that
can we get some of them i'll play them
phoenix i want you to do a dive tomorrow
like you've never done before i want
every single swastika every single
confederate flag every single mean sign
i'm a mean man and i'm out here
protesting for freedom with the truckers
supposedly there was one and it is very
unclear whether it was planted or not
and one bad apple doesn't ruin the bunch
there have been thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of protesters out
there but all trudeau has
is you guys are racists you guys are
nazis you're homophobes and transphobes
and islamophobes and phobia phobes and
enough is enough so finally
finally the conservative party and their
leader of the conservative party we
played some clips of her candace bergen
not candice bergen
american tv star candice bergen from
murphy brown a different candice bergen
but it would be funny if it was her uh a
different candasbergen like they're
actually kind of lining up and they're
saying we are going to fight this
insanity but trudeau's got nothing now
and what what happens
what happens to someone who has no
principles what happens to someone who
comes in preaching
rainbows and diversity and all of that
nonsense when when they have painted
themselves into a corner because he did
this to himself it did not have to be
this way as i said at the top of the
show there were a couple day window
there there was a window where he could
have said hey you know what we've heard
you guys we're going to scale back some
of this stuff and as we scale back some
of this stuff why don't you guys go home
and we'll talk and we'll negotiate and
all that stuff that was the hope that
was the hope right i played that video
of jordan peterson uh to you guys and
it's like that's what jordan was saying
hey you guys got some wins here so now
let's everybody cool off and let's see
where it all goes but literally about
three hours after that uh trudeau went
in with this emergency power nonsense so
it's like look at him now all you got
man is yeah you guys stand up with the
nazis and it's like it's pure [ __ ]
everyone sees it and don't lose your
nerve canadians i i can only imagine i
know if you i have a few friends i have
a bunch of friends actually in canada uh
but i've talked to gad sad i've talked
to jordan peterson
i've talked to chris pavlovsky from
rumble i've talked to a whole bunch of
people and and you know
it's not fun to live in a country where
you feel like your bank account could be
shut off right where you feel like your
livelihood could be destroyed or the
police might show up at your door or you
can't protest but maybe this is a test
run right for everything else that we've
seen in the world over these last couple
years like can they just get connect
canada to fall can they just get good
canadians to just give up like like the
world was starting to be saved by good
canadians and can they just crush them
now and will we just watch as they crush
them the jury's out on that right like
we can do the best we can to shine light
on this but if you're if you're just
like a decent good human it's not fun to
be like i have to fight my government
today
you know it's not fun to be like oh i
want to buy something on amazon and then
be like purchase denied because they
closed your bank account because you
donated 50 to a trucker who didn't want
a mandate to say whether he had to wear
a mask or not
but this is where we need brave people
and
i don't know that we have as many brave
people as we had say a generation or two
ago right my two grandfathers who fought
in world war ii i have no doubt that you
guys all have those stories as well
um
we need brave people to step up which is
a kind of funny thing because who's
stepping up right now who's stepping up
it's it's that pillow guy yeah
mike lindell remember the pillow guy
he's banned from like every store
because he supported trump and they took
his pillows out of bed bath and beyond
and coals or wherever else you sell
pillows well the pillow guy's trying to
help we've got some info here from
business insider
the my pillow ceo and trump acolyte mike
lindell said he plans to drop pillows to
truckers in the canadian freedom convoy
after his overland shipments were
delayed lindell told the daily beast
that he had since chartered a helicopter
and planned to jettison the pillows over
the truckers using little parachutes on
thursday we need to get the my pillows
to the people he told the outlet
i mean here's where we're at people
we've got a pillow guy who's trying to
send pillows to truckers in canada
they're stopping the pillows from
getting into canada now you've got the
pillow guy he's going to send
helicopters to drop pillows with little
parachutes so that the truckers can rest
in the middle of their peaceful protest
as their psychotic prime minister tries
to arrest them this is a fine mess
you've gotten us into
[Music]
let's do a couple locals comments before
we shut it down for the day uh jean
says
freedom lets you stand on the edge of
the grand canyon and choose not to jump
they think they have to be restrained in
order not to jump ooh
that's good that's good gene that might
be the comment of the day already
anne says instead forbes is going to
give hillary a lifetime achievement
award i mean this is one of those things
it really is one of those things what do
i always say about the mainstream media
it's like you guys don't have to be
great
but all i would request is that you not
be completely horrible like i would love
i really mean this jake tapper if you're
watching the show or brian stelter or
someone at the new york times like if
you guys honestly cover the durham
report tomorrow and really do a great
expose on it a six minute expose saying
well actually they did lie about this
and this is all nonsense and no they
never hired this firm to spy on the
servers and blah blah blah i will play
the whole thing you know what i not only
will i play it i won't i'll just play it
straight up i won't even add a single
bit of commentary i will not show up to
intro it or outro it i'll just relay it
i'll just mirror it on this channel if
you guys can honestly break this thing
down and say it's all [ __ ]
i suspect that you won't but i wish that
you would if it really was
i really do
okay i enjoyed the show today how do you
guys feel
yeah it was great he said it was great
pretty good pretty
pretty pretty good all right uh join me
at reubenreport.locals.com everybody
that's where i communicate with uh with
all you guys directly
as i said my interview it's a mini
interview about a 20-minute interview
with maxine bernier catching you up to
speed on everything going on in toronto
and canada and ottawa the whole place
will be up tomorrow afternoon and we got
a q a for you tomorrow if you want to
get your questions in you can do that
right this very moment at ruben
report.logos.com have a great day
everybody goodbye